portable en main rachel et lilian
parcours le littoral il n'hésite pas à
prendre des clichés de plage non envahi
par les sargasses ces deux étudiants en
bts négociation relation client au lycée
de bellevue ont pour projet de lancer le
martinique challenge littoral magnifique
l'objectif montrer à travers des clichés
qu'il reste encore des places
accessibles propre et sans sargasses il
n'hésite pas à aborder la population
pour expliquer leur action
c'est justement pour eux devaient le
blason de la matinée qui est plein de
touristes de revenir parce que c'est une
mauvaise image et en fait c'est fou
comme vous pouvez le constater
l'occupation magnifique et voilà vous
pouvez participer vous êtes un mot dans
un moment détente on arrivait en sur le
territoire en tunique on se dit est ce
que on va pouvoir profiter pleinement
des plages si c'est pas la famille qui
nous dit ben non t'inquiète pas c'est un
plus ça va moi c'est plus vers les
autres plages où c'est un peu plus
difficile mais franchement avant de
partir on est un petit peu perplexe je
pense que c'est une bonne initiative
pour mouvoir le tourisme ils sont jeunes
ils ont des potentiels je pense que
d'autres personnes vont s'allier à l'eau
projet les clichés réalisés sont ensuite
publiées sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag martinique challenge littoral
magnifique dans leurs démarches et sont
suivis par leur professeur de marketing
qui les encadrent votre aspect de ce
projet la collecte de fonds sur internet
deuxième axe de ce challenge c'est la
cagnotte en ligne c'est une cagnotte
solidaire dont les fonds nous
permettront d'aider d'une manière ou
d'une autre le territoire
une expérience enrichissante pour ces
deux ambassadeurs de la section du bts
nrc qui compte bien mener leur projet à
terme dans notre section n'est amené à
faire des projets scolaires
mais c'est vrai que de mener des projets
extra scolaire permet de nous enrichir
en fait nous parce que ce soit cause
personnellement ou professionnellement
c'est vraiment important pour nous de
mener à bien ce projet et de s'investir
en tant que jeune ambassadeur soit de la
matinée pour aider l'économie
martiniquaise sur ce projet en fait une
initiative citoyenne qui a la volonté de
revaloriser l'image de la martinique